maintenant on passe en français puisque
c'est un événement pour la première
conférence de presse en orbite de
l'astronaute de l'esa thomas pesquet un
astronaute européen mais avec accent
français comme on va pouvoir le
constater la plupart des questions
seront en français de nos collègues mais
on aura aussi des questions en anglais
et nous travaillons avec nos collègues
de la nasa qui a un relais ici qui
s'appelle franck peeters qui est un de
nos grandes controverses y aller assez
et franck qui est là haut sur la galerie
vient de me dire dans l'oreillette que
j'ai ici un petit peu comme lé
présentateur du 20 heures pour me dire
qu'on a trois minutes avant de parler à
thomas vous savez que c'est quelque
chose de très inquiétant presque j'ai
envie de dire ce genre de liaison on en
fait très rarement en fait live ça a
l'air très simple comme ça maintenant on
est habitués aujourd'hui avec skype avec
tout tout un arsenal de d'applications
pour se parler partout sur terre et dans
l'espace
ce genre de liaison et fait relativement
rarement à peu près une dizaine de fois
sur six mois et la raison pour laquelle
c'est toujours un petit peu tendu c'est
que quand vous savez la station spatiale
et à 400 km d'altitude et voyages une
vitesse de 7 km par seconde 28 km heure
est donc le signal voyage jusqu'à
satellite qui redescend au texas avant
de repartir sur un satellite au-dessus
de l'atlantique et revenir sur les
centres de contrôle de lézat qui nous
arrivent ici à cologne au centre
européen des astronautes de lézat si
quelqu'un pourrait ouvrir à gré l option
prise
merci et on est à moins de deux minutes
maintenant de notre appel avec thomas
nous allons commencer de manière
classique avec le le fameux style chic
et miami c'est ce que je vais
dire à la station tout à l'heure on va
voir si thomas peut nous entendre
correctement si jamais il y avait le
moindre perdre la moindre perte de
signal
on le saurait à l'avance j'espère et
sinon dans tous les cas on fera le mieux
pour y palier nous allons parler à
thomas pendant 20 minutes en ce moment
mes collègues de la nasa au centre de
contrôle de houston le fameux houston we
have a problem center est en train de
voir que tout marche bien pour thomas
dans la station spatiale
on attend d'eux thomas qu'il soit
installé confortablement dans le
laboratoire de lézat columbus que vous
avez ici en modèle réduit et quand vous
regardez le la station ici en haut nous
avons à gauche pour vous le module
columbus de lézat c'est un petit peu là
la salle la chambre de l'europe dans
l'espace là où thomas pesquet va passer
le plus clair de son temps pendant les
prochains pendant les mois à venir pour
les six prochains mois de sa mission
proxima et maintenant nous devrions être
très proche de l'événement j'attends la
commande de mes collègues du centre de
houston pour rappeler la station
spatiale encore vingt secondes avant de
prendre contact avec la station spatiale
et j'attends maintenant de manière
imminente
l'appel de la nasa pour commencer le
contact avec thomas attention ça va être
maintenant
stake in à sanaa une colonie amis
bonjour thomas on entend très bien et
nous avons ici des journalistes qui sont
réunis à cologne qui attendent de te
poser leurs questions
et on commence tout de suite avec la
première question bonjour thomas je suis
gay jolie de france info vous allez être
notre envoyée spéciale pendant tous ces
mois
ça fait plusieurs jours que vous êtes
dans l'espace on a envie de connaître
vos premières impressions comment vous
vous sentez comment votre corps s'adapte
comment ça va
thomas newman on sait à part le fait que
j'ai oublié mon micro on sait on s'est
adapté très vite on n'a pas été bon là
du tout tout le monde et tout le monde
se sent super bien finalement travailler
en impesanteur c'est hyper naturel au
bout de quelques heures on s'oriente
prendre les virages en trois dimensions
montent et descendent travailler à
l'envers donc tout ça c'est ça s'est
très bien passé on a un peu je suis un
peu gonflé j'imagine parce que on à
l'afflux des fluides et du sang vers le
vers le cerveau au lieu de tomber dans
les jambes mais c'est normal ça va se
résorber au bout du bout de quelques
semaines ou quelques mois
et puis voilà on s'adapte doucement à la
vie ici sur l' iss est immense c'est
plein d'équipement il y en a absolument
partout donc il faut vraiment s'orienter
ça prend un peu de temps mais on n'est
déjà pas mal installées mais mes
partenaires d'expédition sont des
vétérans qui connaissent par coeur il
m'aide beaucoup et me voilà au bout de
quelques jours je suis super content
d'être là et on a déjà commencé a bien
travaillé depuis depuis lundi vous
dormez bien
je sais pas si vous m'avez entendu et ce
que vous dormez bien là haut dans le
ciel
ah pardon il n'en avait pas entendu je
dors très très bien je dors comme un
bébé en fait c'est super agréable parce
que on dort en flottant comme ça on est
on est retenue juste à la la paroisse
nos petites cabines individuelles qui
sont juste derrière la caméra que vous
pouvez pas voir avec un sac de couchage
qui est accroché au mur et on flotte
comme ça on allait on a les bras qui
flottent un petit peu c'est super
reposant moi je trouve ça encore une
fois je trouve ça assez naturel je me
sens super bien et est en mieux et puis
voilà c'est parti pour six mois donc il
heureusement bonjour thomas christine
chapelle de tf1 je voudrais savoir est
ce que la station spatiale et comme tu
l'avais imaginé bonjour christie mais
ben non écoute c'est beaucoup mieux que
ce que j'avais imaginé
c'est vrai qu'on était on était quand
même très familier avec le avec la
répartition des modules avec les
équipements parce qu'on s'est entraîné
pendant des années moi ça fait sept ans
que je la prépare cette mission donc on
est censé connaître les moindres boulons
les moindres équipements mais pourtant
quand on arrive ici ce qui frappe c'est
l'impression de liberté on peut vraiment
on peut vraiment faire ce qu'on veut ce
qui frappe c'est une nouvelle façon de
travailler aussi parce que il faut pas
laisser échapper ces outils ou son micro
par exemple que sinon on leur trouve un
endroit complètement différent de là où
on l'avait laissé ce qui m'est arrivé 30
secondes avant d' avant de prendre
l'antenne mais mais au final je trouve
ça très très pratique c'est vraiment une
nouvelle manière de travailler mais qui
est tellement plus confortable que sur
terre voilà alors je parle même pas de
la vue mais là vu malheureusement comme
on a commencé à travailler dès le début
j'ai paru encore plus beaucoup en
profiter mais ce week-end je compte
passer la plupart de montendre là dans
la coupole à et puis c'est de prendre
quelques quelques photos sympas et puis
regardez un petit peu dehors raconte non
quelle est la journée type dans l'iss
la journée type dans les ss on va se
lever à 6 heures du matin à peu près
ensuite on a à peu près une heure une
heure une heure et demi pour se préparer
prendre sa douche faire le petit
déjeuner etc
enfin comme comme sur terre et puis à
7h30 on commence par une grande une
grande conférence avec tous les centres
de contrôle le centre de contrôle de
lézat notamment à munich en allemagne
on passe en revue le plan de la journée
on pose nos questions on répond aux
questions qui ont été posées et ensuite
on c'est parti pour le un peu le
marathon de la journée on est on est
encadré aidé par le centre de contrôle
qui va nous répondre à nos questions qui
va nous donner des informations on
échange beaucoup par radio et puis et
puis voilà le plan nominal ça va être
des activités pour entretenir la station
donc hier par exemple j'ai testé tout le
système d'eau pour m'assurer qu'il ya
pas de ya pas de bactéries indésirables
ou de choses comme ça ça ça m'a pris un
moment et puis j'ai déjà réalisé des
expériences dans columbus de nouvelles
expériences qui était prévu pour ma
mission que j'ai déjà commencé installé
hier une avec des surfaces innovantes
qui sont auto nettoyante en fait sur
lequel les bactéries à des repas j'ai
répartis un peu partout dans la cabine
et une pour le traitement de l'eau qui
faisait partie des activités dire il ya
aussi un dosimètre active qui est juste
là à mes pieds
partout autour de nous c'est des
équipements scientifiques donc c'est à
ça qu'on s'occupe la plupart du temps et
puis parfois aussi a aussi dépanner des
réparations et par exemple on a passé
une bonne partie de la journée aussi
c'était pas prévu à réparer les
toilettes quand cassé dès le deuxième
jour donc ça c'était un peu la tuile
mais en même temps je me dis que ça
arrive au début de la mission ça y est
on a on a utilisé notre notre quota de
malchance et maintenant ça devrait
marcher jusqu'à la fin du mois j'espère
ça y est ça est hadid a dit spécule m de
profondeur dans une famille comme inside
roquettes soit qu'ils ne simule un but
magnifique de jimi hendrix et mix rock
nickelback business trip hop et de moi
ce que tu peux traduire rapidement cette
réponse en français oui plaisir jules
ben oui je parle souvent mes proches en
fait on a le téléphone sur ip je peux
les appeler tous les jours ce qui est
rassurant pour eux après m'avoir vu
disparaître comme ça dans le dentielle
sur une fusée je sais que c'était
c'était important qu'on puisse parler
qu'on puisse voir donc le téléphone
quasiment tous les jours je peux appeler
ma famille et mes amis pendant quelques
minutes
et puis une fois par semaine le week-end
on a une vidéoconférence et puis la
première arrive le week-end prochain
j'espère leur faire visiter un petit peu
lié à seysses comme je vous la montre un
peu avoue aujourd'hui mais de manière
limitée
bonjour thomas simon rose et rfi
justement ce décollage tu as mis sur
facebook que c'était l'expérience la
plus incroyable de ta vie est ce que tu
peux nous le raconter et puis même les
quelques heures qui ont précédé comment
s'est passée cette journée particulière
oui c'était c'était assez spécial il ya
beaucoup de rituels donc les l'ailé
russe nos partenaires russes ont
l'habitude de lancer des des hommes dans
l'espace depuis des années ça se passe à
peu près toujours de la même manière
depuis le début c'est ça qui est assez
intéressant
donc on prend notre notre dernier repas
sur terre ensuite on est on est inspecté
par les médecins on est on est
désinfecté de la tête aux pieds pour pas
amener des des bactéries des virus dans
la station on se retrouve au building
d'assemblage du soyouz on enfile losc à
fond les tests on parle à la famille à
travers la vitre et ensuite on a la
scène du départ où on salue les
responsables russes on monte dans le bus
et là c'est vraiment la dernière fois
qu'on voit la famille sur terre le bus
s'éloigne nous emmène la fusée on monte
dans un ascenseur qui m'a paru
interminable parce que à chaque et à
chaque étage musée mais bon ça y est on
est arrivés finalement n'était pas
arrivé donc c'est quand même assez haut
une fusée soyouz et et puis on est on
est aidé pour descendre dans la capsule
par par des techniciens russes on
s'installe on checke tous les systèmes
ont fait tout notre chaque liste nos
procédures avant décollage et puis à la
fin on a comme on finit souvent en
avance on écoute un peu de la musique
donc on avait une playlist spéciale que
d'ailleurs j'ai partagé sur les sur les
médias sociaux sur mes comptes twitter
ou facebook pour les gens que ça
intéresse et puis voilà ensuite on
attend tout bêtement le le décompte
final qu'on a entendu dix fois au
simulateur mais là c'est c'est pas tout
à fait pareil on s'est serré la main
avec oleg et peggy puis ensuite c'était
parti quoi on consent l'accélération qui
augmente commandes augmentent jusqu'à là
jusqu'à la séparation du premier étage
où là on est on est vraiment écrasé dans
le dans le soyouz et puis quand le
premier étage se séparent il ya une
espèce de sensations de ralentissement
on a l'impression qu'on tombe en fait
c'est assez impressionnant et puis ça
recommence à accélérer avec le deuxième
étage troisième étage une minute 48
comme ça d'accélération et puis au bout
d'un moment tout s'arrête et encore une
fois c'est comme un c'est comme un coup
de pied aux fesses on est on est
injectée en orbite comme ça et là tout
commence à flotter dans la cabine et la
sai on s'est serré la main on est on est
arrivés dans l'espace et tout de suite
après on a commencé à bosser parce qu'il
ya des manoeuvres a réalisé avec le
soyouz pour nous amener sur la bonne
orbite
mais voilà donc à peu près
si cette heure après le décollage on a
pu dormir et là on a annoncé tous
écroulé parce qu'on avait c'était quand
même une assez longue journée
deuxième jour un peu plus de manoeuvre
troisième jour rendez vous avec la
station spatiale
et puis moment un peu d'émotion quand on
la voit se dessiner dans le ciel
c'est quand même impressionnant c'est de
la science fiction de rejoindre ces
espèces de base spatiale qui flottent
dans le ciel quand on la voit pour la
première fois c'est une vraie il devra
gifle à travers la figure parce qu'on se
dit ah ouais c'est pas que des photos ou
à la télévision mais puis après le sas
où on retrouve nos collègues nos amis et
voilà c'est le début de l'aventuré
justement comme ça c'est ouvert on t'a
vu regarder partout alors que la station
a priori tu as connaissez par coeur
est-ce que c'est aussi mal rangée qu'on
le dit alors c'est pas en fait
bizarrement c'est extrêmement bien
rangée on n'a pas l'impression comme ça
parce que c'est vrai que ça fait
fouillis de deux câbles ou d'équipement
au mur qui les ordinateurs partout mais
mais la performance c'est qu'il ya des
gens au centre de contrôle qui suivent
sa une immense base de données
et chaque fois que je cherche un petit à
petit
objet en particulier par exemple le
drapeau et zac est derrière moi je me
suis dit tiens je vais mettre un drapeau
les a jetés la main c'est ce que je vais
trouver ça il ya des millions d'objets
des millions d'endroits où chercher
derrière les panneaux deux ans au
plafond sous le plancher c'est
impossible de juste cherché comme ça de
mémoire que j'ai appelé le sens de
contrôle qui m'a dit ben voila tu le
trouveras exactement dans cet endroit là
qui est derrière moi qui est codé et je
suis allé ouvrir ce tiroir j'ai trouvé
ce drapeau donc c'est quand même assez
phénoménale de voir que qu'on arrive à
suivre ça de manière très précise et
d'ailleurs pour chaque activité ça
commence toujours par aller chercher
l'équipement et on va être envoyé un peu
partout dans la station parle par la
procédure qui nous dit récupère tel
équipement un tel endroit tel équipement
à tel endroit on assemble tout ça on
fait notre notre activité ensuite c'est
important de bien les remettre à la
bonne place le maillon faible un peu
dans tout ça c'est d'équipage
si janot remet pas les choses exactement
à leur place on les retrouve pas on les
retrouve pas ensuite j'ai utilisé un
tout petit outil dans le dans la boîte
ou titres colombus hier qu'on a
utilisées pour réparer justement les
toilettes désolé d'insister mais est
gelée remis très attention de manière
très attentionné bas parce que sinon
c'est perdu et après on n'a pas des
doubles pour tous malheureusement donc
c'est un challenge mais c'est un
challenge qui je pense est tous les
réussit tous les jours par les équipages
et surtout par le centre de contrôle un
bon jus de tomate
corey quoi chine avec 1,5 de l'activité
at your heart of life plc pression et
ils prennent une à une
sawyer et benq johnny rock qui traque
dans les monts europe top par mamy qui
se joue des abbesses non yacoub
halloween est affreuse collectiviste et
en français thomas la question c'était
sur le sport tu est constituée afin de
judo de rugby doit pas quitter vous je
pratique beaucoup de sport qu'elle est
quelles sont les valeurs et les qualités
que tu as
retenu de ces sports pour équiterre dans
ton métier d'astronaute allait
effectivement les sports ça a été ça a
été vraiment beaucoup pour moi c'est une
grande part de ma jeunesse et une grande
part de ma jeunesse et de mon quotidien
encore aujourd'hui évidemment faut être
en forme en bonne forme physique pour
être un astronaute mais c'est pas ça le
plus important le plus important c'est
c'est qu'un sport collectif comme le
rugby ça apprend et bien jouer ensemble
à être un joueur d'équipé ça apprend un
communiqué ça apprend à bien gérer sa
frustration ça apprend à être un leader
ça apprend à être parfois follower comme
disent nos amis américains donc parfois
on n'est pas le leader ben faut quand
même faire de son mieux et puis c'est
comme ça ça fait partie du boulot
voilà donc c'est des choses comme ça que
j'ai appris par exemple au rugby et puis
le goût de l'effort le goût du
dépassement de ce challenge est tous
assez important dans ma vie
professionnelle évidemment parce que
sinon je ne serais pas arrivée là faut
beaucoup de chance mais il faut aussi
faut aussi un peu de détermination et le
judo en particulier ça m'a appris les
choses comme le respect comme la
patience comme le goût du travail comme
ben comme une certaine éthique en fait
que certains mouvements qu'on va répéter
un million de fois avant de les
maîtriser il faut pas espérer y arriver
du premier coup il faut passer il faut
pas se frustrer
il faut accepter la défaite il faut il
faut travailler dur donc toutes ces
choses là ça s'apprend à l'école oui
mais ça s'apprend aussi beaucoup je
pense dans les sports et dans les
activités tout bonnement tout bonnement
associative en fait les activités
d'après l'école ça c'est important on
essaiera d'en parler on parlera beaucoup
d'eux pendant la mission de l'école
parce que c'est important il faut il
faut que les jeunes et les enfants
fassent de leur mieux à l'école c'est
sûr mais il faut aussi je pense moi
s'intéressait à tout être ouverts parce
que c'est ça le monde moderne
buffett a stick weight machines à tisser
un prêcheur pote every day we left hand
ball c'est ce combat que 15,1 des
perspectives
bonsoir thomas olivier sanguy cité de
l'espace une question qui vient de
michel chevalet de i télé
est-ce que passer 48 heures dans le
soyouz n'a pas aidé à s'acclimater à
l'imposante heures étant donné qu'il est
plus petit que l' iss
ouais bon jour obligé c'est une bonne
question écoute je sais pas te répondre
parce que j'ai pas pu faire la
comparaison
peut-être peut-être mais tu sais même
dans le soyouz où on est on est quand
même un peu au plafond on est quand même
un peu sur le côté parce que justement
c'est tellement petit qu'il faut
vraiment utiliser toute la place
disponible donc donc on a passé beaucoup
de temps à faire un peu du tetris comme
ça pour faire rentrer du tetris en trois
dimensions pour faire entrer trois
membres d'équipage dans un volume assez
petit et puis il fallait dormir enfin
les manger fallait vivre pendant deux
jours donc c'était un peu l'expédition
dans l'équivalent d'une petite voiture
d'un très très long road trip
peut-être que ça a aidé je ne sais pas
répondre à cette question tout ce que je
peux dire c'est que moi j'ai la chance
et mais avec mes collègues on a eu la
chance que ça se passe très très bien
il ya 30 % des gens qui sont un peu
malin dans mon temps c'est normal ça
veut rien dire
et puis ça disent pas au bout de
quelques jours mais nous ça nous est pas
arrivé heureusement parce qu'être malade
dans le petit volume du petit volume du
soyouz ça aurait pas été très agréable
donc tu répondras michel que
malheureusement je ne sais pas répondre
à sa question mais mais en tout cas je
suis content qu'on n'ait pas été malade
voilà merci beaucoup thomas ici depuis
le centre européen des astronautes on te
souhaite une très bonne journée en
orbite and see you soon
merci à tout le monde merci à tout le
monde à cologne au centre européen des
astronautes et à bientôt
et voilà ça s'est rapidement le contrôle
de houston qui viennent envoyer notre
astronautes thomas pesquet à sa journée
normale il peut continuer à travailler
maintenant
merci à tous d'avoir suivi notre stream
sur le web
merci à tous d'avoir été ici pendant
l'événement on se retrouve à bientôt
pour un autre événement ici à cologne au
revoir